you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
california catastrophe as thousands of
barrels of crude oil leak into the
pacific ocean
all of britain's electricity will come
from renewable sources in just 14 years
time the prime minister promises
and keeping it spherical the
round-the-world sailor dame ellen
macarthur tells me why she's so
passionate about the circular economy
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the mayor of a californian city has
described an oil spill off the coast as
an environmental catastrophe the area of
sea affected is home to endangered
species including humpback whales and
snowy plovers
dead birds and fish have already washed
up on the shoreline as emergency workers
race to set up booms on the ocean
surface
well the accident happened off the coast
of huntington beach a city 30 miles
south of los angeles now heavy crude
spilled into
into the pacific ocean between the
city's pier and newport beach that's a
distance of more than five miles now
more than five hundred and seventy two
thousand liters that's three thousand
barrels leaked into the area
the spill thought to be from an
underwater pipeline now covers about 13
square miles
the suspected broken pipeline is
connected to an offshore oil platform
called platform ellie and ellie is
located nearly nine miles off the coast
of huntington beach and it's thought the
potential source of the league is around
four and a half miles off the coast
well amplify energy also operates ellen
and eureka nearby and all three of the
platforms have been shut down following
that spill
well let's speak to our u.s
correspondent greg milam now who's live
in huntington speed beach so greg
describe the scene for us now
yeah we've just had an update actually
from the uh the people who are working
to uh to look after the wildlife it is a
very sensitive wetland area as well as
being a beach area and they've just
given an update on the number of birds
they've seen coming in oiled it's only a
handful at the moment and they say they
are optimistic that makes them
optimistic that the impact might not be
as great as they first feared when they
heard the news of that spill uh over the
weekend but they will be here for weeks
and months they say because the impacts
will be felt for that long uh the oil
they say will be continuing to come
ashore uh for days here at the moment it
looks just like dirty sand that there
are a few tar
globules but it's not coming across come
ashore in in huge amounts and that is
their hope that will continue but you're
talking about a stretch of six miles and
an awful lot of oil out there in the
ocean uh at the moment they're trying to
use equipment to recapture much of that
oil
out on the uh the ocean surface where
it's spilled they're also using booms to
to protect some of the areas
on the shore and heading into those
wetlands that are very sensitive the
mayor has talked about it being
ecological uh disaster just because of
how sensitive this area is
ecologically and they've seen spills
here back in the 60s in the 90s
that did huge ecological damage you
mentioned what happened that pipeline
that runs several miles offshore to an
oil platform and then to a rig and they
believe they've stopped the flow of that
oil but certainly locals felt that they
were smelling this this tar smell in the
air much earlier than this spill was
reported and for that reason they
believed this was happening earlier and
then the response operation was was able
to be put in place but big questions
about coastal drilling already here in
southern california they will grow after
this you can be sure
greg thanks very much indeed
now he doesn't make his keynote speech
at the conservative party conference
until wednesday but today boris johnson
revealed that there'd be a substantial
environmental announcement in it that
within 14 years all electricity produced
in britain will be from renewable or
nuclear energy
looking at the progress that we're
making
in wind power where we lead the world
now in offshore wind looking at what we
can do with other renewable sources
carbon capture
and storage uh with with hydrogen
potentially
we think we can get to
complete clean energy production by 2035
well our chief political correspondent
john craig is at the conservative party
conference in manchester so john boris
johnson plans to showcase his green
credentials in his speech ahead of cop
26 of course but how's that likely to go
down with the party faithful there in
manchester
the big worry is uh what this means for
people's energy bills there's a lot of
concern here uh amongst uh
representatives and of course members of
parliament about the cost of living we
heard from the chancellor today warning
about that
the prime minister has always said he
doesn't want to do any of these
environmental measures if it means
people's energy bills goes soaring but
having said that it's a major
announcement he's going to make on
wednesday
and another big pledge some will say
it's ambitious
but
he is determined to make the cop 26
summit next month a big success and so
he keeps coming out with these new
targets now he will be criticized by
environmentalists for relying too much
on nuclear power but obviously the main
concern here here is uh people's energy
bills their their their gas their and
their electricity bills and so on but
he's determined to do it he says that uh
not only is uh the gov the government
here committed to ending petrol and
diesel cars new cars by 2030 this other
pledge five years later and uh he says
that it'll mean for the first time uh
the uk is not dependent on hybrid
hydrocarbons uh coming from overseas
with all the fluctuations in supply and
so on
john thanks very much indeed
well let's just take a look at the scale
of the challenge facing the government
over the next next 14 years and you can
see on our data dashboard the real-time
power mix
where fossil fuels right now are making
up 48 of the uk's power you can see
renewables are currently at 38
and nuclear constitutes 14
of our power right now
now in some of today's other climate
news now pope francis hosted a pre-cop
26 summit today where 40 religious
leaders issued a joint climate appeal
ahead of the un climate summit in
november they're calling for concrete
solutions to save the planet from an
unprecedented ecological crisis
christian leaders including the
archbishop of canterbury justin welby as
well as representatives of islam judaism
hinduism and sikhism have all signed
that appeal
environmental groups including
greenpeace have launched a campaign to
ban fossil fuel adverts in europe they
say adverts and sponsorships by oil and
gas companies are as harmful as tobacco
promotions the groups plan on launching
protests and eventually gaining a
million signatures from eu citizens
indonesia has created a museum made
entirely from plastics to raise
awareness of the ocean's plastic crisis
the exhibition is made from more than 10
000 plastic waste items including
bottles bags and straws which were all
collected from polluted rivers and
beaches
now she once sailed single-handedly
around the globe so it's perhaps
appropriate enough that dame ellen
macarthur has stuck to the spherical
theme the sailor turned environmental
campaigner has recently begun advising
the scottish government on green issues
and is a passionate advocate of the
circular economy well i spoke to her
earlier today and she began by
explaining exactly what that means the
best way to describe a circular economy
is to look at today's economy which is
linear so we take a material out of the
ground make something out of it and then
the products get thrown away within a
circular economy you take a material out
of the ground you make sure that product
stays within the economy for as long as
possible so it's all about eliminating
waste and pollution to keep that value
in the system circulating the materials
that sit within the products that sit
within the system and most importantly
regenerating natural capital so actually
making sure the biological materials
have the ability to regenerate land
and it sounds like a pretty fundamental
change to how we're doing thing things
now are you talking about a whole
wholesale systemic change to our economy
and if so that's a very big ask isn't it
it's a big ass but it's a massive
opportunity and if we look at today's
economy
we take a material we use it and then we
throw it away in the long term that that
simply can't run we have finite
resources available to us and also we're
releasing many greenhouse gas emissions
within a circular economy you have a
massive opportunity to reduce emissions
by keeping those products and materials
in use in fact 55 percent of carbon
emissions can be cut through switching
to renewable energy which is very
understood but a circular economy can
help to tackle the remaining 45
so bringing this back to the cop talks
what does success at that meeting look
like to you i think an agreement around
what needs to be financed is crucial
obviously finance is a huge part of
switching from a carbon heavy intensive
economy to one which uses far less
carbon a lot of the renewables
incentives have been brought into place
in the developed world but what about
other incentives how about incentives to
how we make products and use products
how about incentives to help farmers
farm in a different way and businesses
to run in a different way that's where
the conversation needs to go as well
and you've just been appointed an
environmental advisor to the scottish
government so what's your view on what
their priority should be there's
obviously a very clear switch to
renewable energy but within circular
economy it's about helping businesses
bringing in legislation to build that
circular economy so how can scotland
lead the way to build a circular economy
working with businesses working with
farmers working with actors within the
economy to switch from that linear
straight line to that circular economy
which is ultimately regenerative and
restorative and has a massive impact on
carbon emissions
so day melon as a yachts woman you broke
the world record for the fastest solo
circumnavigation of the globe in 2005.
so how do you go from that to promoting
circular economies
in some ways it's very different of
course you know i never thought i'd be
speaking to you about economics for
example when i was racing around the
world but actually when you race around
the world you set yourself a goal and
that goal is to break the record or to
get back alive or win the race but
actually within this new challenge the
circular economy this is about the
future of our global economy it's about
the future of humanity and actually it
really matters and it's really important
that we have a goal set to what that
could look like and that's what led me
to the circular economy
looking at how can we use resources in
our world that's a goal this isn't about
running away from a problem but it's
about running towards a solution and
since we set up the alamo carter
foundation in 2010 our goal has been to
look at the economics into a circular
economy to accelerate that transition to
a circular economy to truly understand
what that looks like globally and we now
have a network of thousands of
organizations and governments across the
world working on that path
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by tessa khan
founder and director of uplift and james
woodhousen visiting professor of
forecasting and innovation at london
southback university and we're going to
be discussing whether the uk can run on
100 clean electricity by 2035 and if
countries should ban fossil fuel adverts
that in a few minutes time
[Music]
what we found in 2020 was that many
people were drinking more than they
usually would at the height of the
pandemic
this research they were publishing today
shows that most people have returned to
their pre-pandemic levels of drinking
however for some people for people who
are already drinking at levels are
putting their mental or physical health
at risk which we refer to as high-risk
drinkers a third of those drinkers are
still drinking more than they usually
would
which implies this data implies that
these habits are now becoming ingrained
anyone can be a high-risk drinker and
many people who drink at risky levels
might not be aware of it for this
research we used a world health
organization validated tool which
involves three questions and
looks at how frequently people drink
how much they drink in one occasion and
how frequently they binge drink
however
definitions can be complicated and it
doesn't help if people to recognize
their own drinking so we would recommend
everyone sticks to this 12 chief medical
officers guidelines we're drinking no
more than 14 units over a week
ideally over three or more days and that
everyone plans in at least three drink
free days during the week
our advice would be to visit our website
drinkaware.com.uk
and complete our self-assessment tool to
get a really good understanding of your
drinking and what it might mean for your
health our website has lots of hints and
tips to help you cut down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
it'll be windy with persistent rain
central parts and showers elsewhere
long drain will become largely confined
to northern england during the morning
with blustery showers developing widely
to the south
scotland ireland and northern ireland
will be mostly fine just a few showers
there east anglia will turn wet later
and gales will develop on north sea
coasts the unsettled windy conditions
mean the atmosphere will be well mixed
so the air pollution index where one
means low pollution and 10 means very
high will be low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're going
to get straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with tessa
khan environmental lawyer and founder of
uplift which aims to help move the uk
towards a fossil free future and also
joining us is the visiting professor of
forecasting and innovation at london
south bank university james woodhousen
so good to see you both welcome
so our first subject is boris johnson
has said that the uk power grid should
be a hundred percent green by twenty
thirty five so is that an achievable
target a tessa can't you first of all do
you welcome this target and is it doable
yeah anna i mean in short it is doable
and it's most certainly the kind of
ambition that we desperately need to see
from this government um but we can set
targets like this until the cows come
home the really important question is
whether or not this government puts into
place the investments and the policies
that are needed to massively scale up
our zero carbon energy sources and just
as importantly to break the lock that
fossil fuels currently have on our power
supply
and that requires the government to do
two things it requires it to stop giving
massive subsidies to oil and gas
producers in the uk so we know that in
the last five years since the uk
government signed the paris agreement on
climate change it's handed out 4 billion
pounds in public money to oil and gas
producers in the uk um and the other
thing it needs to do is it's got to say
no
to the opening of new oil and gas fields
like the cambo oil field which it's
currently astonishingly considering
giving approval to which will lock us
into reliance on fossil fuels for
decades to come okay let me get james's
reaction and james just before you do
come back i just want to show a
statistic from last year from 2020 uh 43
of britain's electricity was generated
by renewables so there's a way to go i
did notice you laughing at one point
during what um tesla was saying there so
why was that what's your reaction
well i'm very suspicious of the doctrine
that we're really uh subsidizing fossil
fuels but i'll about to test her on that
but she must admit that
we are subsidizing renewables or
intermittent sources of energy supply
which deliver 43 of our power one day
and then two percent another day we're
subsidizing them a whole lot more now if
we're looking at positive solutions it's
pretty obvious that uh boris has had a
hidden conversion to nuclear power
i'm in in favor of that but we must
recognize that uh conservative
governments and the coalition before
them have completely dithered on nuclear
power they've dallied with the chinese
communist party they've drawn up
ridiculous contracts in the case of
hinckley point they've angered hitachi
so the japanese firm pulled out they've
dithered on small modular reactors
and most of the nuclear fleet will be
retired by april the 1st april fools day
on 2024.
so if you want to make the targets
you've got to do a lot of investment in
nuclear such as we're unprepared really
to make the last few years now i believe
they're going to uh announce two more
nuclear power stations big deal okay
tessa what's your take on nuclear some
people say that you need a kind of
dependable source of energy for when the
sun doesn't shine or the wind doesn't
blow what's your take on it
well anna there are a number of
different scenarios for how we can get
to that zero carbon electricity grid by
2035 and the challenge is that if we
want to keep costs down which is a huge
concern obviously especially in light of
the gas price crisis i mean new nuclear
power plants cost tens of billions of
pounds as size well c will cost and it
will take another 12 years to build so
that doesn't seem like a great solution
given the other solutions that are ready
to scale that are desperately
underfunded at the moment and cost is
important isn't it james because people
are worried about higher bills for
starters but also people are worried
about a transition away from jobs they
might have people in the fossil fuel
industry are concerned about losing
those jobs
well completely right and they're right
to be concerned i think what we've got
we've got to be very uh crystal clear
here uh um anna which is really when
boris says you know oh i'm so worried
about gas prices in the same breath he's
saying he's going to protect consumers
by making gas more heavily taxed so that
they shift in a nudge-like fashion to
electricity this uh ladies and gentlemen
it's the class war by another means it
will mean more expensive uh gas cooking
and heating for those who retain the old
supply
they will be put in a difficult position
if his ridiculous targets uh ever come
to fruition they certainly won't by
2035.
you know the the whole opinion in
environmental things is people need to
lay out more money to be better people
uh for the right kind of clean so clean
pure energy okay and i don't buy it okay
i'm pretty sure that tessa would come
back at you but i'm afraid we've got to
move on to the other subject right now
sorry tessa we've got to move on because
more than 20 climate groups have
launched a campaign today aimed at
banning advertising by fossil fuel
companies across the eu in a similar way
to the ban on tobacco advertising
implemented nearly 20 years ago in the
uk so tessa should adverts for fossil
fuel companies be banned what's your
take
yeah well look anna as your report made
clear the vast majority of ads by fossil
fuel companies are green washing which
is to say that they are misleadingly
giving the impression that fossil fuel
companies are interested in investing in
green energy and zero carbon solutions
when actually they're doubling down on
investments in oil and gas and
extracting fossil fuels um we also know
of course that fossil fuels are
endangering our health and our rights in
the most serious way imaginable so yeah
it's a good idea to ban fossil fuel
advertising um but the most dangerous i
think
effect of these advertisements is that
it's lulling our governments into this
false sense of security that the fossil
fuel industry can be trusted
to lead this transition away from
oil and gas and polluting sources of
energy and i think the uk government has
fallen into that trap as we've seen in
the deal that it struck with oil and gas
companies here in the uk in the form of
the north sea transition deal which is a
voluntary framework with incredibly weak
targets um so you know the the oil and
gas lobby in the uk is already accessing
the government in all kinds of ways it
certainly doesn't also need the
opportunity to advertise as well do you
think that's right james i mean the the
analogy that's been made is with the
tobacco industry which have has had
adverts banned
what do you make of this i mean fossil
fuel companies will say we want to be
able to communicate with our customers
what do you think
well i've got to ask tessa whether she's
ever clicked on a banner ad because i
never had and i never have met anybody
who's ever looked at an internet banner
ad now i've also got to ask tessa in the
nicest possible way have you read this
book it's published in 1957 and it said
that advertising you know was very
influential with people have you read
this book it's published in 1963 by
marshall mcluhan saying that the medium
is the the message and the advertising
is very influential advertising is not
influential
the plebs as green people like to
imagine the population at large do not
buy advertising they don't accept what
advertising says because they got more
brains than greens credit them with it's
all part of the class just come back at
that very quickly
yeah i mean i guess you'd wonder then
why it is that fossil fuel companies are
plowing hundreds of millions of pounds
into advertising if it's so ineffective
and they have managed to
keep a hold on our power systems okay um
and our power supply despite all we have
to leave it there i'm leaving i'm
leaving the last
shrug and shake up the head there with
james i haven't got time to hear from
him on fray but we must leave it there
thank you both very much indeed
thank you do stay tuned because we've
got sky news tonight coming up next and
the met commissioner cressida dick rules
out quitting but also a review of police
culture that's coming up next
[Music]
you